david le financement aura donc été moins
fructueuse prévu pour monsieur péladeau
voilà vous l'avez dit pierre karl
péladeau a atteint le plafond de
dépenses qui avaient été fixés par le
parti québécois avec 400 mille dollars
de frais engagés mais son équipe n'a
récolté que 285 mille dollars en
financement
résultat vous allez voir sur le tableau
pour le clan pierre karl péladeau donc
une dette de 130 2000 $ ses adversaires
ont des dates beaucoup moins importante
mais il avait engagé aussi des vrais
beaucoup moins important bernard
drainville vous le voyez 3600 dollars de
dettes
martin ouellette 385 dollars alexandre
cloutier jean françois lisée eux atteint
l'équilibré si je peux dire et pierre
serre et dégage même un petit surplus de
14 dollars mais je les ai un peu plus
tôt les budgets étaient extrêmement
variables d'une équipe à l'autre celui
de pierre karl péladeau était
considérable par rapport à ses
adversaires
pour vous donner une idée il a dépensé
cinq fois plus que celui qui a permis de
terminer deuxièmes donc alexandre
cloutier
on s'entend pierre karl péladeau aurait
sans doute les moyens de rembourser
lui-même ses 132 mille dollars mais la
loi ne lui permet pas bien sûr dans ce
sens il ne peut pas signer un chèque
justement pour éponger cette dette ça
veut dire que son équipe doit
recommencer le financement auprès de
militants pour un événement qui est déjà
terminée ça peut vous sembler curieux
mais ça s'est déjà déroulée dans le
passé ça arrive assez fréquemment que
des hommes et des femmes politiques
complète ce genre d'exercices avec des
dettes
vers 19 heures son porte parole nous a
affirmé par écrit que le chef de
l'opposition helle établir un plan de
remboursement pour cette dette de 132
mille dollars
voilà merci david bonne soirée